I worry about a generation of kids whose
rights not only have been taken away but
who have been taught by overcautious
school administrators to scorn whites to
not believe in them and question them
when the newspaper staff at this
California High School wanted to write
about the firing of a popular teacher
administrators reacted in all the wrong
ways starting with an attempt to censor
the student reporters and ending with
the suspension of the journalism teacher
who tried to stand up for their rights
rights are rights regardless of whether
you exercise them in a school or whether
you exercise them out in the real world
the staffers of the award-winning high
school newspaper the matador take their
roles as student journalists seriously
and want to cover the stories that
matter to their classmates so it's no
surprise that they began investigating
after the school's principal pulled a
popular first-year teacher and debate
coach into his office and terminated his
contract he didn't deserve to be fired
he hadn't done anything wrong so we
wanted to fight for him to come back
student protests formed it was a classic
student newspaper story popular teacher
fired with no explanation of course as a
newspaper you want to report on things
that have a large impact and because
engineering had touched so many people
they wanted to report on it because of
the reaction that it caused it's still
unclear why new yen was let go and he
declined to comment in this video but he
waived his right to privacy in a
handwritten letter to the matador staff
and rumors began circulating about a
personality conflict with the school's
principal Jim Schofield in all my
previous years of going to San Gabriel
High School mr. Schofield didn't really
come into our classes very often but
that past year having mr. knee and he
was coming in and checking on him all
the time and it just didn't seem natural
when I first started out on the whole
Andrew knew in case a couple of editors
told me that they need a photographer to
cover am sit-in my main interaction was
with the principal Jim Schofield when he
came out and he saw that there were
students standing in solidarity and also
that I was taking photographs and
covering the incident he was someone I
reign after a student reporter asked
principal Jim Schofield to comment on
new u.s. firing he fired off a series of
Concerned emails
newspaper Advisor Jennifer Kim in this
one he orders her to kill the story and
suggests a fluffy profile piece instead
the principal's decision is very
problematic it's pretty clear that
writing a story about a controversy over
a teacher being fired is protected by
California statute ken white is a First
Amendment attorney and writer for the
popular law politics and culture blog
top hat he says free speech rights can
get complicated when you're talking
about public high schools but that we
can turn to the Supreme Court for some
guidance for a long time it was assumed
that public high school students didn't
have any more free speech rights and
their principals wanted to give them the
key there was the case of Tinker versus
Des Moines during the Vietnam War some
students wanted to wear black armbands
to protest the war the school didn't
want to let them do it what the Tinker
Court said and what was really the
high-water mark for student free speech
rights was that students have the right
to express themselves as long as it does
not disrupt the educational environment
ever since tinker there's been a steady
march of school administrators arguing
that speech causes disruption and the
Supreme Court for the most part going
along with them in the Hazelwood case
what the Supreme Court said was it
didn't really matter whether or not the
speech in a student newspaper met the
tinkerer test whether it caused actual
disruption or could be expected to the
school paper if it was controlled by the
school and regulated by the school was
really the school's speech and the
school didn't have to be a platform for
speech it didn't like so that reasonable
restrictions on what goes into the paper
are going to be upheld while the Supreme
Court retreated on student speech rights
California marched forward and
strengthening them what the California
statute does is takes the protection
further you can write things in the
paper and the school can't punish you
for it unless they're actual incitement
to disruption now in San Gabriel you had
a paper that wanted to talk about the
controversy over a popular teacher being
fired the
vegetables initial excuse was that they
couldn't publish it because the teacher
has privacy rights what the students
were doing was reporting they were not
purporting to make an official statement
on behalf of the school they were doing
what a student reporter should do which
is to ask why to ask people how they
feel about it and to write what they
find out the staff of the matador knew
their rights and pushed back and listing
the help of the ACLU and the student
press Law Center
they began showing up at school board
meetings raising hell and demanding
answers instead I found in the district
bullies harasses Italians
I've always been an adamant believer of
standing up for what you believe in
especially in the face of adversity and
with what's happened with the school
especially at the Alhambra Unified
School District telling us you know you
can't do this when in fact we are you
know protected it's kind of reaffirmed
my belief and it's also taught me to be
a little bit more skeptical about
Authority in a way
finally the principal relented and
allowed publication but this ordeal was
far from over
newspaper adviser Jennifer Kim also
oversaw the publication of the yearbook
and during summer yearbook camp she had
a run-in with the new principal after
she allegedly tried to influence the
content of their publication to a lot of
people it kind of looks like this is
retaliation for the Matadors coverage
during the summer if this teacher said
to his or her superiors I think you're
breaking the law then that is
potentially illegal retaliation school
board officials and administrators
declined requests for comment but every
month students continue showing up at
board meetings and badgering district
officials about their conduct one thing
that troubles me about this is that the
principal in the school are not only
disciplining kids not only regulating
their conduct but their modeling they're
teaching them values and it bothers me
when people like principals and teachers
model and teach anti speech values